it's important to protect your api from
unauthorized access
and one way to do this is with api keys
and so in this episode we will cover how
to create an api proxy
that requires an api key and then also
how to create an api product
how to add a developer how to register
an
app and then call your api with an api
key
[Music]
when an app makes a request to an api
proxy that is configured to verify
an api key the app must supply a valid
key
at runtime the verify api key policy
checks that the supplied api key
is one valid hasn't been revoked
and matches the api key for the api
product
that exposes the requested resources
if the key is valid the request is
allowed if the key is invalid
the request results in an authorization
failure
so let's first start off by creating a
proxy visit apogee.google.com
next click develop api proxies create
new
this is the build a proxy wizard select
reverse proxy which is the most
common fyi enter the following values
like this
click next on the common policies page
select
api key this option automatically adds
two policies to your api proxy
click next on the summary page select
the optional deployment checkbox for
your environment
next click create and deploy and finally
select edit proxy to view the overview
of the api proxy
from here you can view the deployment
status which takes a few seconds to
complete
to view the policies that were added by
the wizard let's select the develop
tab you'll see that two policies have
been added to the proxy request
preflow of the api proxy one is
verify api key which checks the api call
to make sure a valid api key is present
sent as a parameter the second is a
remove query param api
key which is an assigned message policy
that removes the api key after it's
checked
so that it doesn't get exposed
unnecessarily click the verify api key
policy icon in the flow view and
look at the policies xml configuration
in the lower code view
the api key element tells the policy
where it should look for the api key
when the call is made
by default it looks for the key as a
query parameter called
api key in the http request
the name api key is not special it can
be any property that contains the api
key
next let's try to call the api first
let's directly access the target
in a web browser go to the following
address mocktarget.apigee.net
this is the target service the api proxy
is configured to forward request to
you should get this successful response
hello guest
now let's make a call to the api proxy
to see how it's being protected by the
policies
we will make a curl command using the
external internet phasing hostname
if you do not have one setup i have
included instructions in this video's
description
note that in my case the external ip
provided by the external load balancer
is configured with a dns registered
hostname
we can call the api using curl and a
command line terminal
such as the cloud shell from your google
cloud project
at console.google.com because of the
verify api key policy you get the
following error response since it did
not pass a valid api key
if we didn't configure that policy you
would get the same successful response
we saw before
now close your cloud terminal great so
now let's get an api key
first we'll create an api product by
returning to the apigee console
and select publish api products
and click on the plus api product
enter the product details for your api
product first an internal name
and note you cannot use special
characters and once created you cannot
change it later
next enter the display name which can
use special characters
or you can let it default to the name
which is used in the ui
and you can edit it at any time next add
a description of your api product
then check the box to have it allow
access to your eval environment
and change the access level to public
also check the box to automatically
approve
access requests you can leave quota and
the allowed oauth scopes
unfilled for now next scroll down a bit
to the api resources section and click
plus
then select the api proxy you just
created then click add
in the path section click add a path and
enter a single slash
click save next we're going to simulate
the workflow of a developer signing up
to use your apis
a developer will have one or more apps
that call your apis and each app gets a
unique api key
this gives you the api provider more
granular control over access to your
apis
and more granular reporting on api
traffic by app
so let's create a developer by selecting
publish developers
in the left menu and click plus
developer and enter the following
in the new developer window and click
create now let's register
an app by selecting publish apps and
click plus app
enter the following data in the new
developer app window
click the developer box to select a
developer you just created
then in the credentials section ensure
never is selected
so that the credentials for this app
never expire
next click add product and select the
product you just created
and finally click create
now let's get the api key by clicking
show in the key field
you can access this page later by going
to publish
apps and selecting your app notice that
the key
is associated with the product you
created
select and copy the key which you will
paste as a query parameter
using the documentations template and
ensure there are no
extra spaces next open your cloud
terminal once again
and paste this curl command and now when
you call the api proxy
you will get hello guest as a response
congratulations you've created an api
proxy and protected it by requiring
that a valid api key be included in the
call
however note it's a good practice to
pass the api key
in a header rather than in a query
parameter the reason is because headers
do not appear
in the browser history or network logs
which could present a possible security
risk
and so i have linked instructions on how
to do so
and there you have it a quick
walkthrough on how to protect your api
from unauthorized access and friends if
you found this episode helpful
you can click like or subscribe to the
channel cheers